candace owens is the host of candace she
joins us tonight to unravel this mystery
so so here kenneth thanks so much for
coming on so here's george shows does
not live in austin texas don't think he
ever has he's not actually from this
country originally why would he want
austin texas to have fewer police
officers on the street
that's a very good question and first
and foremost i'm so tired of left
pretending like we've picked george
soros to be our boogeyman like oh he's
on a bad guy but there goes the right
talking about george soros every time
this man spends money it it is towards
an effort that is going to undo american
civilization notoriously obviously he
defunded black lives matter all the
writing all the protests the open
foundation society which which is his
foundation gave money to all these
causes and you ask yourself why he's a
billionaire if he wanted to help people
or help black people he doesn't need to
give to black lives matter he can give
it to tons of other causes that actually
do work to help black people and don't
destroy their communities but here we
have him again
in the same type of initiative going
against police officers and you ask
yourself why well you know if i'm going
to fathom an idea or theory as to why
he's doing this george soros is a man
that made his money and investment so we
have to ask ourselves what is he doing
what is he invested in that would his
investments would go long he would do
well in his investments if america was
undone if major cities were undone i
don't know maybe he's going long on
china why would he benefit from an
america america doesn't really exist
i've also said this to you many times in
the past tucker and i want to say it
again i think the leftist after more
than anything is the federalization of
the police force i've been saying this
over and over again look at the american
story right now it is the exact same
story of every country that has
converted from a capitalist thriving
society into a socialist society they
need to federalize the police force to
make sure that the federal government
has the most control it's the only thing
that makes sense again the question why
does george soros want to see that why
does george soros want to see the
collapse of america well he has to be
invested in a country that isn't america
i think that's a really good hypothesis
i think also there is hate at the core
of this i mean why would you
systematically go to cities you've never
lived in
and make them more dangerous you know
that's going to result in more murders
everyone i mean it's not complicated
but you do it anyway you clearly are
angry at the country
yeah or or you're just a person that
that wants to make money i think i
really do believe that money is the root
of all evil and i think that george
soros is a person that cares
passionately about money i think he
cares about becoming successful i don't
think hate is enough to drive george
shows of course at the core of this is
always hate right you have to hate
america you have to hate american decide
or at least not care for it very much
but the sad part is is that the people
that are suffering are the people that
live in austin people that have lived
there for so long who are now suffering
who are fearful that they're not going
to have a police force a local police
force that can protect its citizens they
want things to get so bad in austin so
bad in new york so bad in chicago that
just like lori lightfoot is calling for
in chicago we need help sending
reinforcements please somebody send
something from the federal level i think
you're going to see that happening a lot
across this country
but the real crime is criticizing a
billionaire
you can't do that you're a bigot exactly
oh yeah
absolutely i mean i remember i
criticized him and talked about his
money as well and they accuse you of
being anti-semitic and i'm like i didn't
originally even know that he was jewish
i'm talking about where he's spending
his money it's not good
a lot of people are intimidated
you're not though candace owens
appreciate your coming on tonight hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else